hello everybody and welcome back to
let's play limbo
alright we got the rain going which is
gonna help somehow I don't know
hopping along we got water I suppose
we owe
who's quite out of here
Oh
ah what the hell
really really why not just make a level
spike to the bottom actually there's
nothing here yep there's nothing
all right what oh I got to go through Oh
what can I just restart checkpoint kill
me kill me
my body's ready day come on
fine
let's load up the chapter oh these Seth
tells me how far in the game I'm gonna
lift uh I gotta go through all this
again boo boo I say I boo you yeah yeah
yeah run away away doglike creature I
shall lose your Bohus rawr whoops
that must have been scary point llamo
get you a mortgage I'm a scary monster
yeah totes scary man engage I first
deliver I made it rain Oh
okay so now up here and then we do
something out before we jump in the pit
and they do a specific I don't know ooh
a chain I didn't see that before
hope fill up with water maybe it was so
amazingly obvious that the game
developers didn't think that anyone can
make that mistake
probably
oh okay
hahaha really oh no hmm
hmm
maybe I can climb up
how did the law get over there now
what
now the logs over there
anyway
I wish you do I push you
maybe if I just pull the log over I
would
ah you gotta be kidding me once again it
was so amazingly obvious that I oughta
seems stupid to figure it out huh I
climb on you
high jump on me I swing on
I'm Alan
I jump on you head jump on you again
making progress hello is anybody home
was that
is that
you okay that was not what I wanted but
okay cool I'm not used to getting
anything I want
haha oh yeah hello
slag down awesomely jump
a half Confucian is water dirty
who was that
what's moving on the ground there
No
so here's an air
ever time Fuli oh my ha ha Hausa
does that was it I miss you oh no oh no
oh no oh no oh no I need the box
I need the box I needed the box I needed
the box
I know I know already because I am so
smart I'm Jean Marc I'm so smart so
smart ten billion levels of smartness
juice
ah yeah what did y'all yeah
her Chum oh that's scary
what's this a box oh it's gonna be
useful poop
oh no box okay betray me
and flawless execution Oh John the best
Oh box good box for flyers
I'll assume that I might need to pull
this box along
flawless execution or maybe I'll screw
the box box out a hole in it okay Oh
aw crap hub yeah give me oh no it's
still filling rock is there a rock there
oh hell with that
ah crap huh uh
I don't want a day anyway today okay
okay okay but I may have messed up with
a balloon thing yup I messed up with
that believe me I don't know what I was
supposed to do there
Boosh it along oh no I'm drowning
oh no oh I remember because I can't swim
apparently because I'm a loser just a
little kid who can't even swim how
stupid
why what I'm answering
BuChE it alone maybe open this and close
it and Bhushan come on it's gonna be an
awesome shot watch this yep get it
Oh get it in there oh yeah I lose you I
bet you yeah yeah yeah worst day ever
was
I'm so great I don't get these things on
the first try because I want the
challenge crap
ah oh that's what's what happened I was
confused Saracen
and Lala's executed do is this there's a
bug on my seal okay hey what now would
whenever I was totally not trap Doug's a
little bit of an exercise in equilibria
I wonder if this really is free flowing
fluid dynamics or if they got some
pretty scripted stuff in here look
Souths prescriptive that was probably
very scripted okay let me think here so
sure I can't quite make that jump just
yet
sure maybe if I go back and hit the
other lever hmm I don't know if that
would help them hmm it's confusing oh oh
yeah
because of fluid dynamics that's weird
that I'm doing so now if I pull that
lever how that's wrong this is wrong so
wrong I need more water
well y know what so I've let water flow
back in oh maybe it's just uh playing
with different equilibrium states oh
yeah if I utilize it again yeah that'll
totally work
then I shut that off yeah yeah yeah
totes dawg
yeah yeah and then I do oh yeah now it's
good good enough anyway nothing in this
place is good brain maggots brain
maggots no more brain maggots I don't
like the idea of a maggot burrowing
right into my brain
not messing with you me oh I guess I
have to have my brain controlled again
lovely eye polio oh no oh good a damn
you damn you boo
really really really okay
oh it's swinging I got a little where
did you get it get it gonna get ya yeah
okay then I let it get and then I jump
on the box that's in my head it went
through my skull into my head now what
Oh wrong way you're kind of a douche I
piss you okay oops I did whoa
yeah totally yeah what we doing what are
we doing that way obviously this must be
incredibly painful oops
oh that looks like it's gonna blow I
jumped at the wrong point there oh thank
you for me right there for me
Oh
run run get up damn now what now what
there's no
rise up know what
oh the box
thank you
oh crap I could get the box I'm gonna
box I'm now gonna be able to I didn't
get the box and I go backwards and then
I go to get the Box run man Ohi run up
up hook isn't it so strange that the
world is perfectly designed that I'm
supposed to have this thing in my head I
miss you
aw crap that was net crap
crap okay I messed up
boxes
crap maybe something gonna come shooting
out of that trash tube or the pipes
gonna float up ah how handy if I needed
to switch directions anyway
ain't that just the handiest thing you
ever seen huh and then eat it yeah thank
you so much water water is only over
get out here get out of here all right
safe
northern northern Natori all right
that's all the time I got for this part
thank you guys so much for watching and
as always we'll see you in the next part
bye-bye